bonsoir à tous
c'est définitivement super
impressionnant d'habitude quand je suis
sur scène ya des machines entre moi et
les gens je suis pas caissière je suis
dj et du coup je suis venu vous parler
de mon expérience dans le rap
je suis rentré dans le rap par la grande
porte du hip hop puisque vous savez que
c'est une discipline propre au hip hop
et depuis aussi longtemps que je me
souvienne j'ai toujours été super
attirés par ce qu'on appelle
pompeusement les cultures urbaines
mais j'ai mis du temps à être activistes
de cette culture et c'est seulement à 27
ans que j'ai pu participer à une
initiative qui s'appelle le spot on se
retrouve après manifestement et donc
j'ai mis j'ai contribué à installer
cette se tient lieu dédié à la culture
hip hop dans le paysage culturel de ma
ville après un an d'engagement dans
cette expérience jean m'a donné en
charge la co animation d'une émission de
radio sur rage et toutes les deux
semaines dans la cerise sur le gâteau
c'était comme ça qu'elle était baptisé
jeu diffusé une heure de morceaux qui
pour moi illustrer à merveille la façon
dont le rap évolué comme une hybridation
de plusieurs genres et à quel point il
est en mutation perpétuelle
naturellement ça se passe souvent comme
ça on m'a mis des platines dans les
mains et j'ai créé il y a deux ans le
personnage de miles vol pour exporter
toute cette musique en dehors de des
ondes de la radio et des murs de la
radio en fait vous allez me dire que
l'europe pourrait passer pour quelque
chose de misogyne on pose souvent la
question de et être une femme dans ce
milieu qu'est ce que ça fait c'est une
question très agaçante qui revient en
permanence dans les rares interviews que
j'ai pu faire à mon âme à petite échelle
je voudrais que l'europe n'est pas plus
misogyne que le monde dans lequel on vit
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer des
grands acteurs du rap français notamment
que ce soit à youssoufia grubbs valdes
même 10 mai et toute sa clique d'extrême
boys et ce sont des gens absolument
chars nord ils vont me détester
d'anéantir l'art street credibility en
un instant mais je suis sûr qu'ils me
pardonneront donc il faut aussi
comprendre que le monde a changé
c'est à dire que si avant on pouvait
considérer l'europe comme un genre
d'homme et le r'n'b comme cette forme de
rap qu'on laissait aux femmes parce que
elles sont en quête du prince charmant
elle adore parler d'amour et les fils et
doux tout le monde le sait il s'est
passé un truc il y a dix ans et qu'il y
à des acteurs de rapides fin du rap us
majeures qui ont ouvert une brèche je
parle ici de gens comme toril ends
travis cote drake kanye west
ils ont commencé à auto tune et leur
aiguë à arrondir les flots la façon dont
ils posent leurs textes et ils ont
commencé à développer une esthétique de
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le gangster
introspectif et amoureuse et dans cette
brèche des tas de filles se sont
engouffrés notamment des figures que
vous devez connaître et nicki minaj car
diby vous allez pouvoir les voir
derrière moi j'ai pas mis nicki minaj
car didier à côté parce qu'elles
s'aiment pas trop et donc elles ont
investi finalement la place va de baby
aussi nous a fait de sacrés tubes comme
my [ __ ] savez en tant que ça très
profond little sims est une protégée de
kendrick lamar c'est lui qui a lancé sa
carrière et la fameuse princesse nokia
qui évolue entre différents genres
donc voilà la particularité que les
femmes ont provoqué en étant propulsée
sur le devant de la scène c'est qu'elles
ont emmené avec elle des tas de
minorités qui n'était pas forcément
représenté dans le rap notamment la
communauté homosexuelle et toutes les
personnes tous les artistes qui se
réclament du mouvement queer
on a vu aussi des personnes en situation
de handicap et des ethnies venir prendre
la parole sur cette grande scène que le
rap était en train d'ouvrir donc
finalement les femmes se sont largement
imposés dans le dans toute l'industrie
dans tous les maillons de la chaîne de
l'industrie
autour du rav aujourd'hui a réalisé les
clips elles sont bookeuse tourneuse
manager elles sont à la tête de la belle
elles sont beatmaker comme la
fantastique honda girl elle son dj donc
finalement toutes les femmes ont
vraiment investi la place quand on me
dit le rap et misogyne judy nord ça
dégage ça dégage ce qui m'a plutôt
interpellé c'est la façon dont le
capitalisme a récupéré le rap il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui le rap est une
culture musicale absolument dominante
c'est celle qui rapporte le plus
d'argent et elle est exposée par tous
elle est rentrée dans nos codes
vestimentaires allait rentrer dans notre
vie cette culture sauf qu'à la base le
rap est une contre culture
il vient du bronx et il ya 40 ou 50 ans
et est un vecteur de communication qui
permettait à des populations opprimées
d'exporter finalement leurs problèmes et
face à la politique à la police aux
élites
le rap est un enfant rebelle par nature
qui s'est insurgé contre ces pères
récupérer petit à petit par l'industrie
et je vous laisse apprécier la charge
sémantique de ce terme
on devine ancre le capitalisme donc
récupéré dans le giron de l'industrie
musicale
le rapper est devenu un objet de
divertissement est l'objet de ma
démonstration aujourd'hui c'est de vous
montrer à quel point cela peut lui
porter préjudice
et à quel point ça à décrédibiliser son
propos il faut savoir que je n'oppose
pas le l'industrie du divertissement le
divertissement à la pertinence
j'aimerais d'emblée faire le distinguo
je dis juste que des tubes comme des six
america de child is gambino ou rambo
rôle de kendrick lamar n'ont pas faim
n'émerge pas à la même fréquence que des
tubes hip hop qu'on connaît tous mais
qui ont complètement évacué le font pour
privilégier la forme cet aspect
divertissement voilà ce que je pointe
juste c'est le déséquilibre entre les
propositions investi de profondeur et
les propositions qui réussissent un
mariage absolue entre la forme et le
fond
comme on a vu s'opérer un glissement
entre rap conscient et le rap game donc
le jeu il se trouve que en efface en
fait à une récupération de tous les
codes du capitalisme et du patriarcat
donc finalement les rappeurs qui font
partie de ce rap mainstream le plus vu
le plus consommé sans les porte-parole
d'un mode de vie oisif on retourne à
cette sémantique du game où le but est
d'amasser des richesses comme le rap
aujourd'hui ne se fait pas sans clip
sens visuel on a montré on a monté toute
une imagerie autour de cette façon
d'aborder la réussite au sens encore une
fois capitaliste du terme donc dans les
clips qu'est-ce qu'on le voit on a une
mise en scène du dollar du billet qui
volent partout dans les clips qui est
qu'il ya vraiment une présence lourde
dans chacun des visuels au point par
exemple que de gilo dans un dernier clip
avec ses petits copains dj khaled et car
dit on l utilise en fait le dollar en
combustible pour son barbecue
on adore et c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
en crise et du coup elle il ya cette
sacralisation du dollar qui est là il y
à aussi bien évidemment vous en doutez
tous les codes vestimentaires avec la
lame l'omnipotence de la mode et surtout
des marques de luxe qui se sont emparés
de tous les codes et tout l'uniforme hip
hop
donc je parle de la banane de la basket
du jogging qui était quand même quelque
chose qui était institut niel
institutionnalisée pardon par les
banlieues donc les marques de luxe en
fait ont repris sa laurenti tiassé avait
chauffeteau que c'est super plus chers
et donc ils ont quand même mis la main
au travers de la mode aujourd'hui le rap
et la mode ne s'envisage plus l'un sans
l'autre en fait donc c'est assez sûr loi
comme récupération il ya forcément donc
la drogue en masse le champagne qui
coule à flots les coupés sport les
grosses villas avec les piscines où des
jeunes filles très nue se balade et donc
vous voyez à quel point tous les codes
du capitalisme et du patriarcat ont
investi finalement les mains
je ris du rap ce qui est très pervers
c'est que cette industrie a actionné un
levier qui est celui de la précarité
matérielle pour ensuite donner naissance
à une bourgeoisie décadente qui fait
rêver les pauvres et les faits consommer
ça c'est un premier point et un deuxième
point c'est que le capitalisme a donné
lieu au travers de cette bourgeoisie
décadente à une espèce d'idolâtrie de
starification de l'arabe star c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui avec l' influence
des réseaux sociaux les jeunes qui sont
la cible principale du rap us et puis
français et également les jeunes ne
savent plus discerner la fiction de la
réalité dans leur espèce de fantasme de
réussite
il m il aime moins les rappeurs pour
leur musique que pour ce qu'il
représente et qu'est ce qu'il représente
il représente des gens qui ont réussi
qui ont de l'argent qui se sont attiré
le respect de leurs pairs qui se sont
attirés les filles au passage et donc du
coup ils ont cette espèce de de
frustration à vouloir être comme leur
star 7
ce phénomène de d'idolâtrie les
dangereux pourquoi parce que les jeunes
ont oublié ou alors peut-être que c'est
nous qui avons oublié d'enseignés ça aux
jeunes ils ont oublié de développer
cette espèce d'esprit critique qui la
demanderais de ne pas prendre pour
acquis tout ce qu'ils voient alors pour
les philosophes c'est le beat de la
caverne de platon
pour ceux qui préfèrent le cinéma on
n'est plus sûr du matrix c'est
exactement le propos de matrix les
jeunes effectivement dans ce monde
d'image dans lequel on est baigné donc
encore une fois avec le l'épée de
damoclès des réseaux sociaux en
permanence y ont leurs têtes sont
absolument fasciné par tout ce qui est
celle fille ragots nombre de followers
c'est ce qu'il
il s'imprègne de ce truc là
du coup quand j'interviens au travers de
projets socioculturels qui serait
associatifs ou institutionnels
je me retrouve face à désarmer de gamins
qui se disent oui à cédric génial d'être
une râpe star is évacue complètement le
fait que ça demande énormément de
travail que ça demande énormément de
sacrifices que ces gens sont soumis à
une pression qui est au delà de
l'entendement
ils sont passés au rouleau compresseur
des enjeux financiers qu'on a mis sur
leur carrière et on parle bien
évidemment aussi on va parler bien
évidemment de du harcèlement dont ils
font l'objet
quotidien au travers des réseaux sociaux
comme dans leur vie ça les jeunes ne le
savent pas ne le comprennent pas c'est
pour ça qu'il faut effectivement les
éduquer et leur apprendre à bien des
tâches et le fait que les rappeurs ne
sont pas ce qu'ils sont dans la vraie
vie à l'écran je suis sûr qu'ils sont
persuadés que booba est un truand que
valdes et complotistes et que caris &
satanistes incroyable c'est peut-être
vrai mais c'est peut-être fort et c'est
là où effectivement l'éducation joue un
rôle majeur
alors face à ce rap mainstream gonflé de
code pas du patriarcat et du capitalisme
on a une contre-proposition qui est très
forte qui est massive mais petit qui est
peut-être un petit peu moins exposée je
vais bientôt vous parler d'artistes qui
pour moi ont réussi à capter les
maladies de notre époque pour les
restituer donc leur perception
finalement fait leurs créations et
surtout le moteur de la création
d'aujourd'hui et je pense qu'on est tous
sujets à ça c'est la peur de
l'effondrement
l'accolade solo j s'est infiltré dans le
rap gentiment et du coup ça a donné
trois grandes familles que je vais vous
présenter maintenant alors cette
première famille je les appelais les
dépressifs c'est pas très cool mais
c'est un petit peu ce qu'ils sont alors
cette première frange du rap vient enfin
est très marquée par la résurgence du
mouvement emo il faut comprendre et
motion émotion ce ces rappeurs ont un
style qui pourrait se rapprocher du
registre littéraire lyrique c'est à dire
qu'il présente un jeu briser un jeu qui
s'interroge sur son monde et qui
essayent par tous les moyens d'échapper
ou en tout cas de ne pas appartenir ni à
lui même ni à ce monde dans lequel il ne
se reconnaît pas donc vous imaginez bien
qu'on a beaucoup de sémantique de la
drogue
il ya toute une imagerie et par là une
thématique très romantique au sens
littéraire du terme encore
et donc pour illustrer cette première
tendance de nos chers petits dépressif
j'ai pris donc les sucettes boys lille
pipe que vous voyez en haut à droite et
ex access tentation qui nous ont quittés
pour les deux derniers l'un par overdose
et l'autre a été assassiné on va passer
à ses guerres ses on va passer à la
deuxième famille la deuxième famille je
les ai appelés les rebelles ce sont des
gens qui portent un propos éminemment
contestataires et qui comme je le disais
auparavant sont arrivés à pointer toutes
les maladies du monde mais plutôt que de
dire je souffre c'est je suis prêt pour
la guerre c'est ça qu'ils disent donc là
dans l'imagerie on a beaucoup de codes
de l'art mais ils ont des masques à gaz
des gilets pare-balles des rangers aux
pieds des treillis c'était une des codes
visuels qu'on avait avant bien
évidemment mais là ça a pris une ampleur
assez massive puisque aujourd'hui c'est
très marketé c'est vraiment des éléments
de marketing
donc là pour illustrer cette famille et
j'ai bien sûr pris la grande haie may
qui a pointé la catastrophe humaine au
travers de son arceau borders la
catastrophe humaine qui est celle de la
migration
on a en bas en dessous d'elle little big
family qui sont des russes et qui ont
sorti il n'ya pas longtemps un morceau
qui qui est une grosse satire du
dirigeant chinois qui s'appelle lolli
banque très très drôle le pipe aller le
voir l'histoire d'un dictateur amoureux
d'une bombe c'est vraiment fantastique
mais une vraie bombe à une fille une bon
on a ce quart lord qui est un anglais
qui ce crime on appelle ça donc comme
dans le métal dans la culture du métal
il hurle lui il a vraiment ces codes
post apocalyptique à fond et on a grubbs
en bas qui est un rappeur français qui
lui par exemple s'attache beaucoup à la
cause écologique il voyage beaucoup et
les désastres de l'environnement enfin
que dans des sujets l'environnement
l'interpellent beaucoup donc il a sorti
notamment un morceau qui s'appelle
lux belzébuth très très jolie où il
pointe ce genre de problème donc voilà
pour la famille des rebelles et
j'enchaîne avec la troisième famille qui
pour moi est celle qui caractérise le
mieux l'ouverture au monde qui est en
train d'être opéré par le rap faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui comme tout le
monde rap on a des sonorités qui relève
des musiques du monde
on a aussi toutes les langues qui rappe
et qui ont un propos qui défend
finalement l'altérité
on n'y arrivera pas 6 1 on n'ouvre pas
les yeux et deux si on ne fait pas front
ensemble ça permet aussi de faire
émerger les voix des minorités dont on
n'a pas l'habitude d'entendre le la voix
donc il pour illustrer cette famille
j'ai pris tommy cash estoniens qui vient
de sortir un album où finalement toutes
les maladies du monde sont mises en
scène au travers d'une dérive sectaire
c'est incroyable du coup il est gourou
dans ces trucs là on a expliqu qui sont
ces petits copains russes aussi eu sont
recherchés par poutine y sont pas très
ils viennent de sortir un clip en fait
où ils remettent en question de pouvoir
en place et poutine n'a pas trop aimé
ensuite on a d'obscène jude cette
charmante jeune fille qui vient de sud
afrique et enfin on à mojo joujou qui si
je dis pas de bêtises vient de nouvelle
zélande d'une toute petite ethnie dont
personne n'a jamais entendu parler donc
ce sont des gens finalement qui
défendent ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
altermondialisme musicale
je le crois donc je voulais en venir au
fait que qu'il s'agisse d'un discours
fantasmé ou d'un vrai propos sur le
champ notre temps
le rap est un méta discours massif
global et pertinent sur notre société
je pense que on ne peut plus considérer
de ne pas utiliser le rap dans comme une
passerelle en fait entre nous notamment
avec les jeunes
quand enfin si je reviens à mon
expérience personnelle j'ai eu de la
chance de croiser le rap dans ma vie
parce que ça m'a permis de sortir de
l'entrepôt adma catégories sociales et
il m'a permis de me rends compte que je
n'avais plus j'ai envie d'ignorer que la
crise
économique social impact est mon
environnement que ce soit mon immeuble
ma rue ma ville mon quartier c'est
vraiment à une échelle tels que je ne
peut plus fermer les yeux dessus je ne
sens pas citoyenne parce que je paie des
impôts ça ne suffit plus tout le monde
le sait je me sens citoyenne parce que
je suis engagé dans le tissu associatif
de ma ville qui me permet d'être en
contact avec ces jeunes de désosser un
petit peu tous les fantasmes sur le rap
qu'ils se font et de garder la
substantifique moelle d'un propos
engagés en tout cas encore une fois de
cet esprit critique qui est si
primordial dans notre société
je me garderai bien avoir une attitude
moraliste qui est infiniment limité pour
faire passer les messages
effectivement le tissu associatif est
nourri de fonds publics
alors pourquoi on dépenserait nos impôts
dans quelque chose la culture qui n'est
pas forcément essentiel aux yeux tout le
monde alors je répondrai par une
citation de patrick malavieille qui est
un élu de notre territoire qui avait dit
à une conférence de presse que le fait
de ne pas soutenir la culture coûte
beaucoup plus cher à la société
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que une
politique culturelle anticipative est
essentiel et ne peut plus se passer du
rap qui est essentiel merci de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]